Así que estaba muy emocionado, dando saltos por todas partes,
intentando averiguar si podría convertir
todas las oraciones que escucho en esto.
Y me di cuenta de que no es suficiente. ¿Por qué no?
No es suficiente porque si quisiera transmitir una negación,
si quisiera decir "no quiero sopa"
no podría hacerlo mediante preguntas.
Hay que hacerlo cambiando la palabra "querer".
Y si quisiera decir: "ayer quería sopa",
lo haría transformando la palabra "querer" en "quería".
Es un tiempo en pasado.
Así que esto es algo extra que añadí para tener un sistema completo.
Este es un mapa de palabras relacionadas como preguntas y respuestas,
y con estos filtros aplicados sobre ellas
se pueden modificar para representar ciertos matices.
Lo explicaré con otro ejemplo.
Tomemos esta oración: "Le dije al carpintero que no podía pagarle".
Es una oración bastante complicada.
Debido al funcionamiento de este sistema,
se puede empezar con cualquier parte de la oración.
Empezaré con la palabra "decir".
Esta es la palabra "decir".
Pero ocurrió en el pasado,
así que voy a ponerla en pasado.
Haré preguntas como: "¿Quién dijo?", dije.
"¿Le dije a quién? Le dije al carpintero".
Ahora vamos a otra parte de la oración.
Empezamos con la palabra "pagar",
y añadimos el filtro de habilidad para que diga "poder pagar".
Luego la convertimos en "no poder pagar",
y después en "no podía pagar", poniéndola en pasado.
"¿Quién no podía pagar? Yo no podía pagar".
"¿A quién no podía pagar? No podía pagar al carpintero".
Y entonces unimos ambas partes preguntando lo siguiente:
"¿Qué le dije al carpintero?
Le dije al carpintero que no podía pagarle".
Ahora piensen,
(Aplausos)
se trata de la representación de esta oración,
sin usar el lenguaje.
Y tiene un par de cosas interesantes.
Primero, que pude haber empezado por cualquier palabra.
No necesariamente por la palabra "decir".
Y el resultado habría sido el mismo.
Lo segundo es que, si yo no hablase inglés,
si hablase cualquier otro idioma,
el mapa seguiría funcionando en cualquier otro idioma,
siempre que las preguntas estén estandarizadas,
el mapa es independiente del idioma.
Así que lo llamé FreeSpeech [LibreExpresión],
y estuve jugando con él muchos meses,
probé muchas combinaciones.
Y me di cuenta de algo muy interesante sobre FreeSpeech.
Estaba intentando convertir el lenguaje,
las oraciones en inglés en oraciones en FreeSpeech,
y viceversa, una y otra vez.
Y me di cuenta de que esta configuración,
esta manera de representar el lenguaje,
me permitió crear reglas muy concisas
entre FreeSpeech, por una parte, e inglés, por otra.
Así que, podría escribir este conjunto de reglas
que traducen desde este método de representación al inglés.
Y desarrollé esto,
el motor de FreeSpeech,
que toma cualquier oración en FreeSpeech
y la traduce en un texto en inglés gramaticalmente perfecto.
Y al juntar estas dos partes,
la representación y la herramienta,
pude crear una aplicación, una tecnología para los niños con autismo
que no solo les da palabras, sino también gramática.
Así que lo probé con niños con autismo,
y descubrí que se identificaban muchísimo con ella.
Podían crear oraciones en FreeSpeech
mucho más complicadas pero mucho más eficaces
que sus oraciones equivalentes en inglés,
así que empecé a pensar por qué ocurría eso.
Y tuve una idea, y de eso quiero hablarles a continuación.
En 1997, hace unos 15 años,
un grupo de científicos estaban intentando entender
cómo el cerebro procesa el lenguaje,
y descubrieron algo muy interesante.
Descubrieron que, cuando de niño, con 2 años, aprendes un idioma,
lo aprendes con una parte de tu cerebro,
y cuando lo aprendes de adulto,
si, por ejemplo, yo quisiera aprender japonés ahora,
el cerebro usa una parte completamente distinta.
No sé la causa de esto, pero mi suposición es
que cuando aprendes un idioma de adulto,
casi siempre lo aprendes
a través de tu idioma materno o tu primer idioma.
Así que lo interesante de FreeSpeech
es que cuando creas una oración, o cuando creas lenguaje,
cuando un niño con autismo crea lenguaje con FreeSpeech,
no usa ese idioma de apoyo, no usa un idioma como puente.
Ellos construyen la oración directamente.
Y esto me dio una idea.
¿Es posible usar FreeSpeech no para niños con autismo,
sino para enseñar idiomas a personas sin discapacidad?
Así que llevé a cabo una serie de experimentos.
Lo primero que hice fue diseñar un rompecabezas
en el que las preguntas y respuestas se codifican en formas, en colores,
y la gente intenta unirlas y aprender cómo se relacionan.
A partir de esto, creé una aplicación, un juego,
con el que los niños pueden jugar con palabras,
y con un refuerzo, un refuerzo sonoro de las estructuras visuales,
con el que pueden aprender un idioma.
Es un proyecto con mucho potencial, muy prometedor.
El gobierno indio nos compró la licencia hace poco
y van a usarlo con millones de niños para enseñarles inglés.
Y el sueño, la esperanza, la visión, en realidad,
es que cuando aprendan inglés de este modo,
lo aprenderán con la misma competencia que su lengua materna.
Bueno, hablemos de otra cosa.
Hablemos de la expresión oral.
Esto es expresión oral.
La expresión oral es nuestro modo de comunicación primario.
Lo interesante de esto es que la expresión oral es unidimensional.
¿Por qué es unidimensional? Porque es sonido.
Y también porque nuestras bocas están diseñadas así.
Están diseñadas para crear sonido unidimensional.
Pero si piensan en el cerebro,
nuestros pensamientos no son unidimensionales.
Quiero decir, tenemos ideas sofisticadas, complejas, multidimensionales.
Yo creo que el lenguaje es en realidad el invento del cerebro
para convertir pensamientos complejos, multidimensionales,
en expresión oral.
Lo interesante es que,
hoy en día, trabajamos mucho con la información,
y casi todo ocurre en el campo del lenguaje.
Piensen en Google, por ejemplo.
Google rastrea miles de millones de webs,
todas en inglés,
y cuando queremos usar Google,
vamos a Google y escribimos en inglés,
y asocia el inglés con el inglés.
¿Y si pudiéramos hacerlo en FreeSpeech?
Tengo la sospecha de que, si lo hiciéramos,
descubriríamos que los algoritmos de búsqueda,
recuperación de datos, todo eso,
son mucho más simples y eficaces,
porque no procesan la estructura de la expresión,
sino la estructura del pensamiento.
La estructura del pensamiento.
Es una idea estimulante.
Pero veamos con más detalle.
Este es el ecosistema de FreeSpeech.
A un lado, tenemos la representación de FreeSpeech,
y tenemos el motor de FreeSpeech, que genera inglés.
Ahora, si lo piensan,
como dije, FreeSpeech es independiente del idioma,
no tiene ninguna información específica relacionada con el inglés.
Todo lo que sabe el sistema sobre el inglés
se encuentra codificado en la herramienta.
Es un concepto muy interesante por sí mismo.
Hemos codificado todo un idioma
en un programa de software.
Pero si miran dentro del programa,
verán que no es muy complicado.
No es un código muy complicado.
Y lo más interesante
es que la mayor parte del código de la herramienta
no es específico del inglés.
Esto supone una idea interesante.
Podría ser sencillo para nosotros
crear estas herramientas en muchos otros idiomas.
En hindi, francés, alemán, swahili.
Y eso supone otra idea interesante.
Por ejemplo, suponiendo que yo fuese escritor,
pongamos, para un periódico o revista.
Podría crear contenido en un idioma, FreeSpeech,
y la persona que consume el contenido,
la persona que lee esa información,
podría elegir cualquier herramienta
y podría leerlo en su propia lengua materna.
Quiero decir, es una idea increíblemente atractiva,
especialmente para India.
Tenemos muchos idiomas distintos.
Hay una canción sobre India, y tiene una descripción del país que dice:
(en sánscrito).
Significa: "hablante siempre sonriente de hermosos idiomas".
Los idiomas son hermosos.
Creo que es el invento más hermoso del ser humano.
Creo que es la cosa más bonita que nuestros cerebros han inventado.
Entretienen, enseñan, iluminan,
pero lo que más me gusta es que otorgan poder.
Quiero dejarles con esto.
Es una fotografía de mis colaboradores,
mis primeros colaboradores,
de cuando empecé a trabajar
con el lenguaje, el autismo y otras cosas.
El nombre de esta niña es Pavna, y esa es su madre, Kalpana.
Pavna es empresaria,
pero su historia es mucho más notable que la mía,
porque Pavna tiene 23 años,
y tiene parálisis cerebral cuadripléjica,
así que desde que nació,
no puede moverse ni hablar,
y todo lo que ha conseguido hasta ahora,
terminar la escuela, ir a la universidad, fundar una empresa,
colaborar conmigo para desarrollar Avaz,
todo esto que ha conseguido,
lo hizo solo moviendo los ojos.
Daniel Webster dijo:
"Si me quitaran todas mis posesiones excepto una,
elegiría el poder de comunicarme;
con él recuperaría todo lo demás".
Y por eso, de todos los usos increíbles de FreeSpeech,
al que más cariño le tengo,
sigue siendo la posibilidad de ofrecer a los niños con discapacidad
la posibilidad de comunicarse.
El poder de comunicarse,
para recuperar todo lo demás.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)